YIWEN ZHAN: Hello?
Hello, everyone.
FABRICE DIMEGLIO:
YIWEN ZHAN: My name is Yiwen,
and I'm product manager on the
internationalization team
here at Google.
FABRICE DIMEGLIO: My name
is Fabrice DiMeglio.
And I'm working in the Android
formatting, focusing on UI and
right-to-left support.
YIWEN ZHAN: And today we're
here to give you a
walk-through of how to build
your Android apps
for a global audience.
Now before we start,
I had a few
questions for the audience.
How many of you already have
your apps available in a
language other than English?
OK, wow, that's pretty good.
How many of you have your
app available on
more than five languages?
That's great.
What about right-to-left
languages?
Has anyone targeted those yet?
Wow, I'm really impressed.
Now how many of you are
interested in expanding your
app into a more global
audience?
OK, given that you're all at
this talk, you should all be
raising your hand here.
As you can see from this quick
survey, everyone is interested
in internationalizing
their app.
But the process of
internationalization can be a
bit daunting.
And today we're here to teach
you some tips and show you
some tools that make this
process a little easier.
But first, let's take a look
at why it's important.
Android has a lot of global
momentum going for it.
More than 900 million
Android devices
are activated worldwide.
And every single day 1.5 million
new Android devices
are being activated.
In total, over 48 billion apps
have been downloaded from the
Google Play in over
190 countries.
That's a lot of users, a lot
of them international.
Now if your app were only
available in English, how much
of this user base do you think
you've tapped into?
Here's a pie chart of the
internet users in the world,
grouped by language.
And as you can see here, English
speakers make up
approximately a quarter of the
world's internet user base.
To reach the remaining 3/4 of
the world's internet users,
you're going to have to
make your app global.
So some of you might be
wondering, what exactly does
it take to make an app global?
Well, on the left, I have the
Google I/O app in English.
And if I want to release the
Google I/O app in all the
other languages that I wanted
to, I can do so in three
simple steps--
preparing, translating,
and testing.
Preparing involves thinking
about which languages you want
to expand into and updating
your code so that is
internationally friendly.
Translating involves finding
translators well versed in app
translation.
And we'll show you some tools
that make this easier.
And lastly, is testing.
After you get back your
translations, your need to
test them before you
launch your app.
We'll also show you some tools
to make this easier.
So the rest of this talk will
be a deep dive on each of
these three sections.
First, you'll have to
think about strategy
for language expansion.
Which languages do you
want to target first?
There's a few ways you
could do this.
One is by metrics.
You can look at metrics, such as
the top languages that are
being used on the web today, or
maybe metrics specific to
the category your app is in, to
figure out which languages
make sense to expand
into first.
Another way is by
language groups.
Some language groups
are easier to
localize into than others.
So if your app is in English,
it might be a good idea to
start off with other languages
in Latin script, such as
Spanish, French, or German.
Now we've been using
a few terms here--
internationalization
and localization.
What do those mean?
Internationalization is
designing an app such that
it's adaptable for various
languages and cultures.
For example, if you were to
design a layout that works
across all languages and
cultures, that's an example of
internationalization.
It's sort of like a
one-size-fits-all solution for
the next piece, localization.
Localization is the actual
adaptation of your app into a
specific language and culture.
For example, if you want to
launch your app in France,
you'd have to translate your
UI strings into French, and
maybe add some local flavor,
such as French holidays.
That's an example
of localization.
Internationalization, as you
might have noticed can be a
mouthful to say.
So it's commonly referenced as
I18N, which we simply means
there's 18 letters between
I and the N in
internationalization.
Now this reference also
translates over to
localization, which is commonly
referenced as L10N.
So that's it for the overview.
Now we're going to take
a deep dive on how to
prepare your app.
When your app is available in
one native language, such as
English, a lot of things you do
in that language might not
necessarily work when you
try to internationalize.
And now we'll give you some
examples of this and teach you
how to make your app so that's
more internationally friendly.
The first and one of the most
important things to do is to
design a single flexible
layout--
a layout that works across
all locales.
A common pitfall of developers
is to design a layout that's
pixel perfect for the native
language that they're
programming in.
And when they go to
internationalize their app,
realize that the layout starts
breaking across languages.
As you can see from this example
here, a string of text
translated from English into
German and Japanese cause the
text to vary a lot in both
length and width.
German language is a language
that's commonly known for
very, very long message
strings.
And Japanese, along with
languages such as Chinese and
Korean, are known for
being very short.
So you have to keep this in
mind and design a layout
that's really generous
and works
across different languages.
Now the next few pieces of our
tips are a bit more technical.
So let's start with
a snippet of code.
Say I'm building an Android
app that's just a virtual
Android store that sells
Android dolls.
And here is a method in my code
that displays the number
of Android dolls sold
on a given date.
So while this method works
really well in English, it
might not work well you
when you try to
internationalize your app.
Let's take a look at each
of the problems, and how
we could fix them.
Well, the first problem you
might encounter is the
question, how do you get these
strings to a translator, if
they're hardcoded
into your code?
Hardcoding strings into the
application itself is a big
no-no, when it comes
internationalization.
Not only does this make it hard
for you to manage and
organize your strings, it makes
it nearly impossible for
the translator to find them.
You can either give your
translator all of your code
and have them dig through it.
Or you can manually take them
out, give them to a
translator, then manually
put them back in for
every single language.
That's a lot of work.
So what should you
be doing instead?
You should use a strings.xml
file, which is located under
the res/values directory
of your application.
In here, you can list out all of
the strings that are being
used in your application.
And back inside your code, you
can use the getString method,
along with R.string.name
to pull that message
back into your code.
So now you have a strings.xml
file.
And you can easily send this
off to a translator for
translation.
But what else could
be wrong here?
Well, to the translator,
some of these things
make a lot of sense.
And they'll probably know
how to translate them.
But what about some of the
shorter strings, such as the
word, account?
The account to a translator
could mean bank account or
maybe user account.
And maybe these two words can
translate to different things
across different languages.
So in order for the translator
to translate with high
quality, you'll have to provide
a bit more context for
your strings.xml.
The easiest way to do this is to
provide comments about each
string in your strings.xml.
This comment can include
information such as the
background for that string, any
trademarks or terminology
you think the translator might
not understand, or if this
piece of string belongs to
a restrictive part of the
layout, such as a button, adding
in a character limit so
that the translator
can abide by that
Other ways is to provide
context are to send
translators screenshots of your
app, or if your app is
already available in Google
Play, sending them a link so
they can download and try
it out for themselves.
So now the translator has
a bit more context.
What else in this piece of
code can confuse them?
Well, let's take a look at
this piece of text, %1$d.
To you, this is pretty obvious
that it's a parameter.
But what does it mean
to a translator?
It looks like absolute
gibberish to them.
And what if they tried
to translate it?
It would break your code, which
would be pretty bad.
What you should do here is wrap
all your parameters in
xliff placeholders.
Xliff is an international
standard that helps you
preserve your parameters
across localization.
And it works with a variety of
localized tools, including the
one by Google, which I'll
show you later.
So all parameters in your app,
or anything that you don't
want translated, simply wrap
them in an xliff:g tag to
preserve them in the process
of translation.
To provide your translators
with a bit more context on
what each parameter means,
remember to fill out the ID
and example attributes.
So this is getting progressively
better, but what
else could go wrong?
Let's see, this piece of code
works for most quantities in
the English language.
But what about the
quantity of one?
You shouldn't be saying one
Androids were sold on, right?
So in English you can fix this
pretty easily with an if/else
loop in your code using a
special case when it's one,
and say one Android
was sold on.
But this doesn't necessarily
translate over
across to other languages.
Let's take a look.
So unfortunately, plurals vary
across different languages.
And there's no one-to-one
mapping of plurals rules
across languages.
Here's a few examples.
In Chinese, plurals all
exist in one form.
And the word, doll, translates
into wawa, no matter what the
quantity is.
In English, as we all know,
there's two forms--
doll for one, and for everything
else, dolls.
In Polish, there's
three forms.
The word, doll, translates into
lalka, if there's one.
It translates into lalki, if
it's a number that ends in two
to four but excludes 12 to 14.
And it translates into lalek
for everything else.
But it can even more
complicated.
In a language that's specific to
a region of France, Breton,
there's five different
ways you could
translate a plural message.
And each of these ways is
very, very specific.
So as you can see, plurals can
get pretty complex across
different languages.
How do we even begin to
internationalize that?
Thankfully, Android can provide
some support through
quantity strings.
For messages in your app that
involved plurals, remember to
wrap them inside
a plurals tag.
And then for a given language
that you're in, list out all
the various ways you can display
that message, given
the quantity.
So in English, there's two
ways you can display it--
one way for the quantity of
one and another way for
everything else.
But what happens in
other languages?
As you can see, the number of
plural messages that you can
possibly have vary
across languages.
So Android supports the
international standard of six
different quantity types--
one, two, few, more,
and other.
Some of these quantity types,
such as zero or one, are
pretty obvious in
what they mean
across different languages.
Other quantity types, such as
few or more are a little more
vague and mean different things
in different languages.
And there are plenty of
resources online telling you
for a given language
exactly what the
quantity type maps to.
So when you're getting your app
translated, make sure that
all of your strings are
in a plural tag.
And the translator will figure
out which client types work
for that language and translate
the strings
properly for you.
Now back inside your app, you
can use the getQuantityString
method, and then call
R.plurals.name, to pull up the
correct plural string.
And given the quantity, Android
will automatically
figure out which plural string
they should be using, so that
plurals are handled properly
all throughout your app.
So we're almost done with
optimizations that make your
code internationally friendly.
There's one last thing you can
do to update your code.
You'll notice that our string
includes a date.
And as many of you know, dates
are displayed in different
ways across different
languages.
How do we fix that?
Android APIs provide
support here.
You can use a library called
SimpleDateFormat to configure
custom date formats
for your dates.
And in a post JB-MR1 version,
we'll provide a call, called
getBestDateTimeFormat, which
given the user locale, will
automatically figure out the
proper date format for you to
display dates in.
And then you can simply use
String.format, give it a user
locale, the format, and
the date, and it will
automatically generate
the right string
for that given locale.
Android APIs also supports
internationalization of other
values such as phone numbers,
decimals, currencies, and
percentages.
And you can use the libraries
below to make these values
internationally friendly.
Now the last tip is also
pretty important.
And to demonstrate, I'll show
you an example of how Google
did it wrong.
Does anyone know what
movie this is?
OK, it's "Breakfast at
Tiffany's." And many of you,
if you've lived in the United
States and speak English, know
this cultural reference.
So when you go into Google
calendar to create a calendar
event, it's no surprise to you
when the example, they provide
you is "Breakfast at Tiffany's."
You understand it,
and it's cool that it's
a cultural reference.
But what happens when Google
Calendar went international?
Well, in Hindi, the string,
"Breakfast at Tiffany's"
literally translated over into
breakfast at Tiffany's.
And to Hindi users, they
had absolutely no
idea what this meant.
Why are they getting
breakfast?
And who is this woman named
Tiffany's, because they didn't
understand the cultural
reference.
So this is an example of--
even if you translate all your
strings correctly, that
doesn't necessarily mean it's
friendly for that language.
So what should you
be doing instead?
Calendar is working
on fixing this.
Now, in Chinese, if you try to
create a calendar event, it
instead says [SPEAKING CHINESE],
which
simply means to get Peking
duck at a really famous
Beijing restaurant.
This is an example of providing
cultural references,
so that you add local flavor for
the language that you're
localizing into.
So when you're getting your
strings translated, and if you
have any part of your app that
requires local flavor, such as
cultural references or maybe
even holidays in that country,
be sure the translator knows
this and doesn't translate all
those strings literally.
So that's it for all the general
tips and tricks for
updating your code to make it
internationally friendly.
There is now a special set of
languages that require a bit
more support--
right-to-left languages.
And I'll let Fabrice talk
more about this.
FABRICE DIMEGLIO: Thank
you, Yiwen.
So let's talk about
right-to-left support.
Right to left, or RTL is a
natural writing direction for
Arabic, Persian, and
Hebrew speakers.
It represents roughly
300 million to
half a billion people.
So that's quite a lot, and
surely part of this next 6
million people that will use
internet and mobile devices.
It's also related to bug 5597,
which has been filed in 209,
actually end of 209 on our
external bug tracking system
and concerning Arabic
language support.
This bug, up to a couple of
weeks ago, was the most-wanted
bug to be fixed.
And it got roughly
9,000 stars.
So that's quite a lot.
Let's see what we have done.
So first of all, here is a
screenshot of the Setting app,
running on Jelly Bean, on a
Nexus 7 with an Arabic locale.
If you know how to read Arabic,
you will notice that
the Arabic text is rendered
correctly and beautifully from
right to left.
The main issue here is
concerning this alignment.
For example, in the Action bar,
you can see that the text
is aligned on the left instead
of being aligned on the right.
We can also notice, on the other
row, that sometimes the
alignment is not correct, on
the left or on the right.
So it's not consistent.
Last but not least, UI widgets
are flowing from left to right
instead of flowing from
right to left.
So what can we do to
improve the user
experience for Arabic speakers?
Here is the same app, running
on Jelly Bean MR1.
And now you can see that
everything flows nicely from
right to left.
It's total natural direction
for Arabic speakers.
The text is rendered
beautifully
from right to left.
And the alignment is consistent
and on the right.
So what we need is
actually layout
mirroring and text alignment.
How can we achieve that?
Good news!
RTL support is built in into
View and ViewGroup, so that
all UI framework widgets
are supporting RTL.
So I'm listing here six steps.
The first one, one and
two, are compulsory.
Three and four are optional.
And five and six are about
testing your app on pre and
post JB-MR1 and also validating
your work with
native speakers.
So let's talk about the
first steps, the
AndroidManifest first.
We're introducing a new
attribute for the application
tag, called supportsRtl.
And if you supportsRtl equal
true, it means actually that
your app is willing
to support RTL.
And then the framework
will do the necessary
stuff to make it happen.
But also you need to use SDK
targets, the SDK 17 and more,
by activating those APIs--
so basically two little
changes into your
AndroidManifest.
Now step two is about
updating layout and
taking care about resources.
So if you remember well what
you're doing with layout, you
have left and right properties,
so padding left,
right, gravity left,
gravity right.
Now we are introducing start
and end properties.
And those properties are
[INAUDIBLE] once.
And we are considering left and
right as absolute once.
So going from start/end
to left/right is
a resolution process.
And if you're from left-to-right
direction,
start/end means left/right.
And if you are from
right-to-left direction,
start/end means right/left.
So this resolution
process is done
automatically and is two fold.
API level 17 and plus-- so
Jelly Bean MR1 and plus,
start/end are resolved and
override any value you may
have defined for left/right.
If you're API level 17 and
below, start/end are just
ignored, and everything
works as before,
left/right are used.
So for your reference, here is
the full table for start/end
property resolution, three
columns on the left for 17 and
plus and three columns on the
right for 16 and below.
In yellow, I have highlighted
two columns where actually
start/end and left/right are
defined at the same time.
And this is exactly what
I said before.
And you can also notice that w
are trying really hard to get
start/end properties used.
Otherwise, we're just using
left and right.
What are the start/end
properties we're introducing
in API level 17 so far,
Jelly Bean MR1?
It's about padding, drawables,
layout margin, and a bunch of
properties for creative
layout.
Now the second step also
is about RTL resources.
And there's good news here.
Aapt compare is also supporting
RTL through a new
modifier called -ldrtl where
"ld" means layout direction.
So if you look at those two
screen shots here, they are
coming from an app where the
developer decided to include
some drawables for Farsi,
Arabic, and also drawables
depending on the density
of the device.
So if you are running this app
on the device with Arabic
locale, it will pick up the
drawable from drawable-r- the
density of the device.
Then it should go to drawable-
the density of the device and
then to drawable.
But by the virtual introducing
global-ldrtl- the density it
will hijack actually the
resolution process.
So that first it would be
resolving to drawable-r then
into drawable-ldrtl because
Arabic is an RTL language.
And then into drawable-
the density
and then into drawable.
So that's pretty much
the same thing.
OK, everything is resolved
from most
specific to most generic.
Now you're doing step
one and two.
And you're pretty happy when
you start seeing your app
running for the first time
on Jelly Bean MR1.
But sometimes you need
to tune the result.
And tuning is about layout
and tuning text.
So here is, on the left, a
screen shot of the dialer app
I was working on a couple
of weeks ago.
And as you can see, everything
flows nicely
from right to left.
But the main problem here is
the first row of buttons.
Actually, it's the
dialer itself.
It's also doing auto-layout
mirroring.
And if you know how to read
Arabic, you will see that the
first row is saying 3-2-1.
An Arabic speaker would say, no,
that's incorrect, Fabrice.
It should be 1-2-3, which is the
screenshot on the right.
So how can you achieve that?
Well, we are introducing a new
property for View, called
layout direction.
And if you take the example I
was talking about just before,
this is a linear layout
with [INAUDIBLE].
So you can say LinearLayout
android: layoutDirection equal
left to right.
And then everything will flow
from left to right.
You'll forcing the
layout direction.
The API is pretty
simple here--
and
getLayoutDirection.
The most interesting part,
sorry, is about actually the
default value, which
is set to inherit.
Inherit means actually
that the view
doesn't know its value.
It will ask its parent
to get the value.
And if the parent doesn't have
it, it will go up to the View
chain, up to View root.
And the View root would
have the locale--
what is my direction.
This resolution process
is done during the
View measure pass.
And it's done before we are
calling you guys on measure,
so that you're 100% sure that
the layout direction is
resolved before we
are calling you.
Now the path for layout
direction, we have two other
probabilities dealing
with text.
The first one is
textDirection.
And the second one is
textAlignment And they are
using the same pattern
for the API.
TextDirection is all about
defining heuristics, so that
you can define actually
the overall
direction for a paragraph.
The default value
is very strong.
It means actually that the first
strong Unicode char will
give its directionality to the
directionality of the paragraph.
You can also define your
own heuristics.
And you can define, for example,
a char count, where
you would count the number of
characters that are left to
right, and the number of
characters that are right to
left and decide the overall
paragraph direction.
Now let's talk a little bit
about text alignment.
As we have seen before, it
was a little bit tricky.
The default value now if you say
text alignment is gravity.
It means that, as before, you
would be using gravity left,
gravity right, or gravity
start and gravity end.
But the most interesting part
here is that you can say text
alignment view start
or view end.
That means actually that the
alignment of the text will be
at the beginning of the view
or the end of the view.
Using text elements like this
has been really easy.
And as I've done the conversion
of the RLT support
for the Setting app, it was
very useful actually.
Now suppose you have
some custom view.
If you're dealing with gravity
left and gravity right, let's
say you need to go to gravity
start and gravity end.
If you're manipulating gravity,
you need to use
getAbsoluteGravity, so that
you're going from start/end to
left/right.
We've introduced a new API
called onRtlPropertiesChanged,
so that whenever layout
direction, text alignment or
text direction is changing, you
have a call back, and you
can do whatever you want.
Now if you're defining,
redefining, onMeasure, and
onLayout, then you need to do
something, obviously, because
basically your layout was
flowing from left to right.
So you will need to flow
it from right to left.
So measurement can be changed.
And layout will be changed.
But the good news is that
you can always use
getLayoutDirection and know the
current layout direction
or the view.
Last but not least, if you're
dealing with draw and issuing
your own canvas command, then
you're on your own.
We are not providing anything
for doing that.
Now let's talk about
compatibility for pre JB-MR1.
So the good news is that as
before, all new attributes are
ignored from one platform level
to the previous one.
So all new RTL attributes
will be ignored.
So if you're ignoring start
and end, what's left?
Mostly nothing.
So the trick here is actually
to have start/end properties
in addition to the
left/right ones.
So, it's duplication here.
But you need to consider also
starts for extracting actually
those left/right properties into
a start file, and then
providing your own start
file for v17 or -dlrtl.
And that will fix the problem.
A great example here is the
Google Keep app that you may
have downloaded from
Google Play store.
So the Google Keep app is the
first app to support RTL that
has been released
on Google Play.
And as you can see in this
screenshot, the Google Keep
app is running on
Jelly Bean MR-1.
And everything flows nicely
from right to left.
The text is aligned correctly
and beautifully rendered.
And also the notes
by themselves,
are using your layout.
And the layout is going
from right to left.
Now let's talk about tools
support for RTL.
So as I said before, aapt
compiler has been modified for
supporting -ldrtl resources.
But you want to debug
your view hierarchy.
And we have introduced RTL
support for HierarchyViewer.
So as you can see in those two
screenshots, when you're
selecting a view, you can see
many properties that are
related to RTL--
getRawTextDirection,
TextAlignment,
TextDirection, and more.
In a future release, we will
release also RTL rules for
[INAUDIBLE]
so that whenever you're dealing
with RTL properties
Link will check and warn you
if anything's wrong.
Now let's talk about a
small case, which is
user-generated content.
So this case is actually
pretty interesting.
So as you can see in the first
line of the screenshot, I was
formatting some phone number
with a [INAUDIBLE] string.
And sorry, the formatting
is not correct.
It's a little bit strange.
And if you know a little bit
about text rendering, we are
using the U bidi algorithm.
And it's doing the right stuff,
because the presence of
the space and the plus
do some [INAUDIBLE].
So for having the correct
rendering that you see on row
number two, you will need to
use a new class, called
BidiFormatter.
And this BidiFormatter will
be released post JB-MR1.
It will be available in the
framework and support library.
And you will say get instance
for my context Unicode, write
this string, which is the stuff
translators would do
actually, by themselves, by
hand, injecting Unicode marks,
or Bidi control marks.
Now let's talk about some
tips and tricks.
So if in your code you're using
String.valueOf an int,
or any number, any type, then
you should remember that the
format will be Latin.
If you want to have actually a
format corresponding to your
locale, you should use format
with %d as the first argument.
As I said before, don't forget
that get.LayoutDirection is
available anywhere in View.
So you can say
getLayoutDirection equal equal
LAYOUT_DIRECTION_RTL.
And then you will know that
you're in RTL context or not.
I previously said that all
UI framework widgets are
supporting RTL.
GridLayout is one of them.
And GridLayout is supporting
RTL as RelativeLayout.
But GridLayout is a better
layout than RelativeLayout.
So please use GridLayout.
If you're dealing with locale,
getDirectionLayoutFromLocale
from TextUtils is a new API that
allows you to know the
direction of the locale.
[INAUDIBLE]
is also used when you are
dealing with framework calls
at the top of the View tree,
where we are asking the
direction of the locale.
And then if you're dealing with
database, SQLite or any
others, don't forget about
formatting your query correctly.
If you're using format %d, it
will be formatted with the
corresponding locale, and it
will probably not be good for
your database.
And you have SQL exceptions.
So use format with locale as the
first argument, and locale
should be US.
Last but not least--
I've seen this in
several apps--
be aware of numbers in tables
and column names.
That can be also lead to the
same SQL exceptions.
So as you can see, it's
pretty easy to add RTL
support to an app.
And Arabic, Hebrew, Persian
users would be really
delighted to see that.
So we are looking for a while to
have this support from your
app into Google Play.
Now I would like to do a small
demo, if you don't mind.
So I'm switching to a machine.
So this is a phone
put in Arabic.
This is JB-MR1.
And I'm going back to my
machine, and I will use this
awesome new tool called
Android Studio.
So you can see this is
a manifest here--
OK, basic app created
with the Studio.
And here, I have highlighted
that for you, supportsRTL
equals false.
So I'm just writing this
app right now,
pushing it to the device.
And here is what you
see on the device.
Hello, world, centered
with an action bar.
Now I'm going back to my code,
and I'm saying suportsRTL
equal true.
Also please notice that the
target SDK version is 17 here.
I'm pushing the same app,
going to the device.
And now you see that the action
bar is laid out from
right to left.
So let's have a little
bit more fun.
OK, going back here, and gravity
was center here.
So I'm using now another
TextView using viewStart,
pushing the app to the device.
There it is.
The text is aligned
on the right.
So I will pass the clicker
now back to Yiwen.
YIWEN ZHAN: Great.
Thanks, Fabrice.
So now that's it for all of the
tips and tricks in making
your code internationally
friendly.
The next step is to get
your app translated.
Historically, developers have
found some trouble here, in
that they had to search the
internet for high-quality
translators who were well versed
in app translation.
As you might have seen in the
keynote, we're launching an
app translation service that
makes this easier.
Starting now in Developer
Console, you can order
translations for your
strings.xml files in a few
simple clicks.
And you've seen this demo in
the keynote already, so I
won't demo it again.
But what I will show you is what
happens after you order a
translation.
So now I'm in Developer
Console.
And I just placed the
translation earlier today for
my I/O app strings.
And if I were to click on this
button, I can check the
progress of those
translations.
So as you see here, I ordered
my translation for three
languages--
German, Japanese, and French.
And you can see translators
making
progress in these languages.
What happens here is that
translators, working for the
translation companies that
Google is working with, are
busy translating our app in
Google Translation Manager, a
hub central for app
translation.
And if you were to click on one
of these languages, you
can see the translator's
work in progress.
So let me check out the
German translations.
So now I'm in Translation
Manager, the toolkit that the
translator is using to
translate our app.
And as you can see here,
all the strings in your
strings.xml file are parsed out
in a way that's easy for
the translator to understand
and translate.
Let's take a look at a specific
message, and see how
the translator is
translating it.
So you can see here on the left
is the message string
itself, along with
the description.
And we put that description
from the comment that you
leave above that
message string.
So it's important to leave
some context for your
translators through comments.
As you see from the word,
remaining time,
that's a place holder.
This is because this was wrapped
in an xliff tag.
And this placeholder will
now be preserved across
translations.
Let's take a look at a few
other translations.
Just scrolling down, you'll see
that the translator has
made some progress on
the translations.
And then for the I/O Live one,
they left a comment.
So we have comments in this
toolkit to encourage
communication between developers
and translators, so
they can work together to
produce the most high-quality
translations for your app.
Let's take a look at what
this comment says.
So here we forgot to leave
some context for the
translator.
And they're a little confused
as to what I/O Live means.
Is there a trademark?
And should we be
translating it?
And when the translator leaves
a comment, I, as a developer,
will get an email with
that comment.
So I can simply look in that
email, and then come into this
toolkit to respond
to this comment.
Now, I can just tell him, no,
this shouldn't be translated.
Now this translator will get an
email with this response,
and they'll know not to
translate that string.
Let's take a look at a
few more examples.
So at the very end is a message
that's in a plural.
And here, we provide plural
support by offering a
translator up to six ways to
translate any strings that are
listed as plurals.
This allows you to provide
proper plural support across a
variety of languages.
So that's it for the toolkit.
And once the translator's done
translating, they'll mark the
translation as complete.
And you'll be able to
download it from
Play Developer Console.
Now here, as you can
see, the Japanese
strings are already done.
And I can download them.
What happens when
I download them?
What I get is a strings.xml
file, all set in Japanese.
And all you have to do now is
simply put this back into the
right place in your
application.
And your application will
be ready in Japanese.
If you're using Android
Developer Tools, you can make
this process even easier as
Android Developer Tools will
automatically download them into
the correct locations in
your application for you.
So now after this process, your
app should be properly
translated.
If you're interested in trying
this out, this is a pilot
program starting in
Developer Console.
So be sure to sign up for
the pilot program.
And you can find this sign-up
under the APK
page for a given app.
So now all of your strings
are translated.
Are you done?
Not yet.
There's one more step--
testing your app.
The first and more important
thing for you to test is the
layout, making sure that your
app translations didn't break
your layout.
And in Android Studio, as you
might have seen in the
keynote, we're providing a
really easy way to do this,
where you can see the different
layouts for
different locales all at once
and see the translations in
those layouts.
And in the translations
that are breaking,
you have two options.
You can either modify the layout
so that they don't
break, or go back and talk to
your translators, to get an
alternate translation.
That's one piece of testing
you should do.
For the next piece of testing,
I'll start out with a story
for why that's important.
So here's an example of a sign
that's been translated from
English into Welsh.
And to most users who only speak
English and not Welsh,
this looks like a perfectly
normal well-translated sign.
The English makes sense, and
you assume the Welsh down
below also makes sense.
But what does it actually
say in Welsh?
Well, it says, I am not
at the office right.
Now please send over any strings
to be translated.
So it looks like somebody
made a mistake here.
What happened here was the
translator was on vacation at
the time these strings were
sent for translation.
And the people who sent the
translations, who didn't speak
Welsh, assumed that their
vacation responder was their
actual translation.
So they went off and
printed this sign.
So what is this lesson here?
The lesson is that doing just
visual checks isn't enough, if
you don't understand
that language.
What you need to do is speak
to native speakers of that
language and make sure
your app makes sense
in that given language.
So if you have friends or family
who speak a language
that you're translating your
app into, that's easy.
Just hand them the
app, and tell
them to give you feedback.
But what if you don't?
Well, thankfully Play Developer
Console just
recently launched alpha-beta
testing, which let's you
incrementally roll out
your app to a very
small subset of users.
And that way you can get
feedback from these users,
which aren't counted towards
your review, to help you fine
tune your app, before
you launch it to
100% in a given language.
So that's it for all the tips
and tricks and all the various
tools that can help you on your
journey to make your apps
available to a global
audience.
The next step is really easy.
Once you've done all the
preparation, all the
translation, and the testing,
just upload your APK to
distribute in Google Play.
And in the Developer Console,
there are settings where you
can tweak the countries and
languages that you want to
distribute your app into.
So that's it for our talk.
We hope you found it useful.
And we're really excited to see
more apps available to a
global audience in
Google Play.
Thank you.
And if you have any questions,
we can answer--
we have two minutes to
answer questions now.
But you can drop by
office hours later
to ask us more questions.
FABRICE DIMEGLIO: Thank you.
YIWEN ZHAN: Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
YIWEN ZHAN: Question?
AUDIENCE: Hi, there.
Loving the translations, but
my translators are my users
who are great at volunteering.
Can I use that fantastic
tool to let them do the
translation?
YIWEN ZHAN: Yes, that's a great
question, and that's
something that we've thought
about in the past as well.
Right now, we're launching
it only to professional
translators, in that we wanted
to promote high-quality
translations.
But that's definitely the next
step that we're going towards.
AUDIENCE: Can you--
any hints?
Timing?
YIWEN ZHAN: Unfortunately,
I can't promise
anything right now.
But we're definitely keeping
that in mind.
AUDIENCE: That'd be great.
And, I mean, just one point--
the users, they actually know
the context of the app.
And they know what
that stuff means.
YIWEN ZHAN: Definitely,
I agree.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: So if we have an app
that's gone through several
revisions, and it's translated
in several languages, and
we're adding some activities,
adding some new strings, how
do we manage getting just
getting those new strings
translated?
YIWEN ZHAN: Yes, and that's
also a great question.
And that's something that
we're keeping in mind.
Right now, we don't offer that
support in the pilot program.
But we're working very fast to
offer support for that, in
terms of allowing you to
incrementally translate the
new strings in your app.
So that will be coming
really soon.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.
YIWEN ZHAN: Any other
questions?
AUDIENCE: One of the things
that I've found really
difficult is doing the actual
layouts that are agnostic of
text length.
One of the things that we
developed at [INAUDIBLE]
was a text view that
automatically resizes based on
the character length and just
had a minimum size.
So I was wondering if you guys
thought about offering
anything like that?
Because that would be really
useful for getting around the
pain of internationalizing
actual layouts.
YIWEN ZHAN: Yeah, that's
really good feedback.
We'll keep that in mind.
We'll talk to the Android
[INAUDIBLE] team.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Is the translation
tool able to handle things
like XML entities, Unicode
characters, or you've got
anything special
to handle this?
YIWEN ZHAN: Yes, most of those
should be handled within the
translation tool.
So we handle almost all things
that have some sort of
international standard
to them.
AUDIENCE: Great.
Thank you.
FABRICE DIMEGLIO: OK, I think
we need to close.
YIWEN ZHAN: OK.
I think we're out of time.
But if you have more questions,
you can drop by
office hours.
We were also passing out
stickers earlier during the
talk for localized Androids, as
you can see on my laptop.
We have about them available
in 13 different languages.
So if you want more of those,
also drop by office hours.
Thank you.
FABRICE DIMEGLIO: Thank you.
Bye.